good morning Hank it's Sunday January
31st are you ready for some football or
in lieu of that are you ready for some
commercial starring monkeys Scott I love
monkey commercials oh but before I start
the video an important note to
nerdfighters who live in or around
Chicago who are over the age of 21
sorry underage nerdfighters I'll make it
up to you I'm going to be part of mark
phasers live talk show at the hideout on
Friday February 6th at 6:30 it's 5 bucks
it's going to be awesome it's an awesome
bar it's gonna be a great time lots of
cool guests and Mark is a genius more
info in the sidebar and now to the Super
Bowl tank on this most sacred day of
secular America I'm not going to talk
about the moral dubiousness of paying
men to participate in a sport that
statistically will shorten their lives
by 15 years nor am I going to talk about
the weird collective mental illness from
which Americans suffer that causes them
to want to watch corporations sell them
goods and services no Hank today I want
to talk about the football team that is
trying today to win their first ever
Super Bowl the Arizona Cardinals the
Cardinals Hank I haven't heard a
nickname that lame since the English
Premier League's Bolton Wanderers
you guys want to play some soccer hmm
yeah kinda but I also just kind of want
to walk around aimlessly
wait wait wait wait something just
occurred to me is it the Cardinals or is
it the Cardinals oh it's the bird yeah
that's disappointing Hank the Cardinals
have the longest current championship
drought in the National Football League
I'm not gonna say that's because they're
the only team in the league to have a
vegetarian bird as their mascot but if
they do lose Super Bowl 43 they need to
think long and hard about getting a new
more awesome mascot and you will be
surprised to learn that I have some
suggestions one ninja's they're fast
they're tough they're deadly and I think
the ask a ninja guy would be open to
being their mascot to the Arizona
mother-in-law's
or three maybe you want a team name that
celebrates tenacity that reminds your
opponents that they can't stop you they
can only hope to contain you like the
Arizona herpes herpes er
Z's or herpes YZ or her purposes I got a
call Brotherhood 2.0 resident
mathematician and linguist Daniel Biss
hey in your professional opinion what is
the plural of herpes is it like herpes
or purposes or what well then if herpes
is the plural what it what is the
singular
herim so you could be the Arizona her
poems and my final recommendation number
four is the Arizona blood-drinking
silver-haired virgins Hank I really feel
like for all the NFL's success it is
almost completely failed to penetrate
the Twilight fan demographic hank as you
can see here in this professionally
produced Venn diagram there is very
limited overlap between NFL fans and
Twilight errs in fact the only place
where those circles touch is me by the
way Hank when I was trying to confirm
that Edward Cullen was a virgin I
googled is Edward Cullen a virgin I mean
I know that repeatedly in the first
three Twilight books it talks about how
he has never been with a girl
but given the astonishing variety of
sentient beings in the world of Twilight
that doesn't answer my question
but anyway you know how when you type
something into Google it suggests what
you might mean well Hank the most common
question that begins with the words is
Edward Cullen is is Edward Cullen real
no no he is not real he is not real and
he is not possible Hank I predicted
entirely due to mascot superiority the
Steelers will win by six I'll see you on
Tuesday